OK.
Let's talk about anti-virals and corona virus.
There is a big conversation about what type
of therapeutic treatment might best work for
a corona virus.
Until we have a vaccine, there are all sorts
of different things being tested using convalescent
plasma to put the antibodies of recovered
people into the bodies of those who are sick.
There are all sorts of different types of
medications.
But one is anti-virals.
So Rim Desert Vier is an antiviral that is
currently the subject of a number of random
randomized controlled trials and again, also
known as for VVIP of air.
That's a mouthful is another antiviral that's
being tested.
And what it is increasingly looking like is
that to get these medications to work at their
best, whatever the best will be, we're probably
going to have to start administering them
much earlier in the disease progression when
the patient is less sick.
And we're going to talk about why in just
a moment.
But just to sort of orient the conversation
there was this a randomized controlled trial
of Ram Denvir?
We got the results from it last week.
It was given to patients already in serious
enough condition to be hospitalized.
About a thousand people were part of this
are C-T.
There was a placebo group.
And what the study found was that the duration
of the virus was reduced by about 30 percent
in the group that received from decieve year
compared to the placebo group.
Very good.
That's something 30 percent is important.
We know less about whether REM desert vier
was saving people who otherwise would have
died.
The results were not statistically significant
on the mortality.
But one thing in general is that anti-virals
work better when they're taken earlier.
And this is it's not a problem per say, but
it presents a challenge with ROOM Des Vier,
which I'll tell you about in a moment.
But as a general rule, antivirals work better
when they are taken earlier.
The earlier, the better.
Look at the flu, influenza and Tamiflu.
Tamiflu is recommended within 48 hours of
onset.
Not if you've had it for days, not if you're
so serious from the flu that you have to be
in the hospital.
That's considered too late for Tamiflu to
work at its best.
Ideally, you start Tamiflu within 12 hours
of starting a flu symptoms.
If not, you want to start it within 24 hours.
If not, absolutely.
You want to be on Tamiflu within 48 hours.
And the reason why is inherent in how anti-virals
work.
Antivirals don't come in and destroy the virus
or kill the virus, so to speak.
Antivirals prevent the virus from replicating.
When we talk about viral growth, we're talking
about not only the spread of cases, but urine.
Imagine that you're in.
You know, you have two viral cells in your
body.
They replicate and become four and then eight
and 16 and 32.
I think you sort of get the idea.
What the antiviral does is it prevents the
virus from can, can, can continuing to replicate
while the body can fight the virus.
The longer you wait.
The larger the viral load in the body.
When you introduce the antiviral, that's why
you want it started earlier and that's why
room desert here may work significantly better
if we were giving it to people earlier.
What's the problem with that?
Well, the problem with ROOM Desert Viren Coronavirus
is that from desert here is an intravenous
therapy.
It's given at a hospital for people who are
not only well into the disease, but sick enough
to already be hospitalized.
There's also potentially room reservoir supply
issues.
But it would be very difficult to give.
You know, how do you can't give everybody
a room Denvir pill as soon as they test positive
for coronavirus.
There's also a limited supply of hospital
equipment to be doing the I.V. infusions.
You need staff in order to give I.V. medication.
There is not room at hospitals to give everybody
room of your intravenously.
As soon as they test positive.
So this, of course, is all assuming that it
worked.
But these are the conversations we're now
having about an antiviral.
So the upside is that because antivirals tend
to work better when given earlier.
The study that said Ram deserve your short
and disease by 30 percent.
We may be able to do way better than that.
Sick patients can do better with it, but early
in the disease, it may actually do even more
for people who have a corona virus.
The downside is an I.V. drug is start.
It's tough to start giving to so many people.
And since it's done in a hospital setting,
we don't have the space nor the resources
nor the staffing to give everybody room desert
here when they test positive.
Maybe if the supply is increased, you could
give everybody in high risk groups the medication
if it continues to prove effective.
And meanwhile, we're continuing to have other
room of your trials.
It's been opened up for emergency use by the
FDA.
And additionally, we're also testing cholesterol.
Cholesterol is a combination of two HIV drugs.
AV, again, is also being tested.
That's another antiviral.
So that's the latest.
But a growing conversation is maybe the antivirals
have to start earlier and thus may be much
more effective.
Hopefully there will be tests done of that
sooner than later.